testing the myth that a car full of air
freshener could be combustible alley
Jesse and Valerie got a big small-scale
result using a spark for ignition now
they've moved on to the second scenario
a slowly leaking can with a lit
cigarette like cigarettes
they've been watching and waiting for
almost two minutes and that's long
enough that didn't work at all but we do
know our air freshener is flammable the
ratio of air to fuel is crucial for
combustion working on the premise that
they didn't leak enough air freshener
this time they start the spray a full
minute before ignition the lighter is
working but so far no boom well maybe
it's too wet in there maybe maybe it's
trying to come on but since it's so wet
then it's not able to I think we should
keep trying and every five seconds try
it again just to see if it'll dry up and
explode
good idea sounds good by letting the
spray disperse and settle there hoping
to dial in the perfect explosive ratio
of fuel to air and just a few clicks
later
oh I felt it I was literally just about
to say it's not working it's a safe bet
that's exactly what Valerie was thinking
- boom the top flies off and Valerie's
like oh my god my heart yeah I think it
scared you would stare at it for like 10
seconds and you look away and at that
exact moment it would explode more on
the story don't ever turn your back on
science especially when it's an
explosion my god and right at that
moment was when my heart drops Yeah
right there was when I had a heart
attack